[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología
soy valentina torre sánchez y en esta
ocasión los acompaño desde casa a causa
de la pandemia de kobe 19 iniciamos con
la conmemoración de los 15 años que
cumple el primer mensaje publicado en
twitter con el que se inició la red
social y hablamos de cómo está
revolucionaria plataforma de
microblogging logró tanto poder a nivel
mundial pues el mensaje publicado el 21
de marzo de 2006 venía de jack dorsey
uno de los cuatro fundadores y decía
just say now my twitter o solo
configurando mi twitter en ese momento
así se veía la página de ingreso el logo
era verde y no tenía vocales la versión
definitiva se lanzó en julio de 2006 con
numerosas modificaciones su objetivo era
hacer un servicio para amigos familiares
y colegas para mantenerse conectados
mediante respuestas a la pregunta qué
estás haciendo claramente desde su
lanzamiento se han producido muchísimas
mejoras en principio los mensajes tenían
un límite de 140 caracteres y eran
únicamente de texto
con el pasar de los años esto cambió fue
creada la herramienta periscope para
realizar transmisiones en vivo y más
recientemente se activaron las historias
personalizadas que desaparecen 24 horas
después de publicadas llamadas flips
entre otros muchos cambios es evidente
que los creadores de la red social
sabían de su potencial sin embargo no
era fácil imaginar el alcance o el poder
que podía llegar a tener la plataforma
años después twitter se ha convertido en
una herramienta clave de comunicación
que fue fundamental en eventos como el
terremoto de haití y la primavera árabe
y más recientemente en los movimientos
sociales como michu y black light
smarter solo mencionando algunos
ejemplos también se transformó en el
altavoz de políticos y activistas a
nivel mundial sin embargo no todo es
positivo junto con otras redes sociales
es considerado un importante difusor de
contenidos falsos lo que le ha valido
millones de críticas además ha tenido
que enfrentarse a importantes ataques
cibernéticos con el pasar del tiempo ha
modificado sus políticas en múltiples
ocasiones y ha creado filtros para hacer
la red más
y amable a los intereses de cada usuario
hoy en día al menos 350 millones de
personas tienen una cuenta en esta red
social pero la dejamos atrás y salimos
de la tierra para conocer el satélite
que japón envió al espacio hay que
buscar remover basura espacial expert
silva tendrá esperamos que en la próxima
década se envíen unos 10.000 satélites o
más así que habrá un importante
crecimiento en la cantidad de tráfico y
congestión en el espacio lo que
significará que los operadores
satelitales tendrán que afrontar
potenciales colisiones y también una
cantidad cada vez mayor de desechos
espaciales que bloquearán esas vías por
lo tanto el problema sólo empeorará si
no hacemos algo al respecto antes
también para ver la iniciativa es una
creación de la empresa astros que aunque
cuenta con una tecnología a base de
imanes
el programa se llama end of flight
services by astros que cuyas iniciales
en español podrían pronunciarse como
elsa es un piloto o una prueba para
determinar si funciona o no y qué más se
requeriría la misión fue bautizada el
sadi y consta de dos nuevas espaciales
un satélite de servicio de 175
kilogramos y un sartén
cliente de 17 kilogramos lanzados juntos
el satélite de servicio ha sido
desarrollado para eliminar de forma
segura los escombros de la órbita y está
equipado con tecnología de localización
y proximidad y un mecanismo de
acoplamiento magnético el satélite
cliente es una réplica de escombros
dotada de una placa ferromagnético que
permite acoplarse lo que utiliza el sadi
es un brazo robótico rígido por así
decirlo que se engancha magnéticamente y
puede realizar los seis grados de
libertad es decir arriba abajo de
izquierda a derecha hacia atrás y hacia
adelante y todas las rotaciones a un
cliente preparado se le pone una placa
de acoplamiento magnética muy liviana
que permite que el sadi la captura e la
pegue así y la controle
de vigilancia espacial de eeuu estima
que hay más de 28 mil escombros en la
órbita terrestre que deben ser removidos
por lo que esta iniciativa podría
allanar el camino para eliminar basura
en el espacio y de acuerdo con los
responsables la compañía podría empezar
a ofrecer sus servicios comerciales para
finales de 2023 analistas aseguran que
se trata de emisiones con una alta
complejidad debido a la cantidad de
piezas que hay en el espacio ya los
costos que podrían tener tenemos que
tratar de ser eficientes que no puedes
llegar allí y remover todos los
escombros que hay tenemos que decidir
cuáles son más peligrosos cuales
representan el mayor problema porque
puede que sea una gran pieza en una
órbita muy ocupada así que la
probabilidad de colisión es mayor allí
entonces tienes que enfocar las misiones
a piezas particulares de basura que son
las más peligrosas y mantener los costos
tan bajos como sea posible si todas
estas cosas funcionan podría haber un
futuro para este tipo de mercado
y para finalizar volvemos a la tierra y
nos vamos a la ciudad española de
sevilla por esta época del año este
lugar se transforma en uno de los campos
de naranjos más grandes de europa pues
hay alrededor de 50.000 de estos árboles
plantados en la ciudad aunque la mayoría
de las naranjas se envían al reino unido
para fabricar mermeladas son muchas las
que quedan en las calles y se pierden e
incluso son un peligro porque las
personas se pueden resbalar por ello la
empresa de agua potable de sevilla
emasesa puso en marcha un plan piloto
para producir energía con estos frutos
mira es un proceso muy sencillo el 50
por ciento de esa naranja espuma dispone
a través de ese zumo generamos un gas o
un gas que es rico en metano que
utilizamos utilizados para producir
energía a través de un motor de
cogeneración es un proceso muy sencillo
es un proceso que no requiere ningún
tipo de aditivo y un proceso
ambientalmente controlado los primeros
resultados del piloto indican que con 60
toneladas se produce la energía que
consumen 300 viviendas en un solo día y
si se cosechan todas las naranjas de la
ciudad
podría generar energía suficiente para
73 mil viviendas por otra parte la piel
y las semillas que no son útiles en el
proceso se usan para fabricar
fertilizantes orgánicos así llegamos al
final de esta crónica pero recuerden que
pueden repetir este y otros programas en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
[Música]